la chronique de l'écho ce soir avec vous
catherine bonsoir bonsoir à l'économie
on va essayer d'avoir un débat une
discussion un peu plus calme de
s'abonner mariage pour tous mais non
moins polémique mais très intéressante
évidemment avec solidarités nouvelles
face au chômage est une association qui
est national qui a été fondée en 1985
par jean baptiste de foucauld elle est
implantée dans les grandes
agglomérations et il y une antenne à
saint quentin en yvelines depuis 1992 le
but c'est d'apporter un soutien j'ai
envie de dire moral aux demandeurs
d'emploi on va en parler avec vous jean
claude fille bonsoir vous êtes le
président de l'antenne saint-quentinoise
et vous êtes venu accompagné de
dominique bretonnet vous êtes en
recherche d'emploi demandeuse d'emploi
alors je dis c'est plutôt un
accompagnement moral votre association
qu'est ce que vous proposez c'est un
accompagnement solidaire ou tourner vers
tourné vers l'efficacité c'est à dire
que j'ai pas dit elle ce n'est pas
efficace mais le comble et morales veut
pas dire sais pas si c'est vrai que la
caractéristique de l'accompagnement sncc
effectivement de d'abord de prendre des
gens qui souvent sont dans une certaine
solitude donc le dialogue qui vont avoir
avec des accompagnateurs va être déjà
leur permettre de se sortir de sortir de
leur solitude
et va leur permettre du moins nous
l'espérons de retrouver un petit peu de
talent de est d'arriver à filament à
retrouver un emploi
on comprend que ce sont des discussions
des réunions qui sont organisées entre d
un copain accompagnateurs et ça c'est
important il ya deux accompagnateurs à
chaque fois qu'ils accompagnent bon
c'est un peu redondant ce que je vais
dire mais c'est quand même le cas qui
accompagne les demandeurs d'emploi qu'on
se passe ces réunions justement alors
effectivement vous avez raison de
rappeler que l'accompagnement snc se
fait toujours ce qu'on appelle en binôme
c'est à dire que l'accompagner en face
de lui
deux accompagnateurs l'expérience a
montré que c'est très riche très
nécessaire et que ça objective un petit
peu la relation avec avec la compagnie
ces réunions nous les nounous rencontre
hall l'accompagner tout est un rythme à
déterminer ensemble souvent tout tous
les quinze jours tous les trois semaines
voire un mois et nous faisons le point
avec l'accompagner sur ce qu'il est
ce qu'il fait ce qu'il veut faire et
c'est donc c'est un accompagnement qui
prend son temps
c'est important donc
bien se connaître et puis déterminer le
projet professionnel parce que c'est ça
qui est essentiel souvent il ya des
recherches d'emploi qui se font un petit
peu dans une certaine confusion parce
que le projet professionnel n'est pas
n'est pas clairement définie donc l'on
éclaircisse et la pensée de demandeurs
d'emploi et vous le sortez de sa
solitude
dominique breton est vous êtes fait
partie de l'association alors qu'est ce
qui vous a donné veut dire envie juste
pas si on peut avoir envie mais entre et
qu'est ce qui vous a poussé à aller vers
l'association c'était pour sortir de cet
isolement
d'une année à doha pwa déjà j'ai je suis
arrivé chez snc par l'intermédiaire d'un
ami qui vont avait parlé en termes
plutôt positif donc je suis pas je suis
pas arrivé par hasard
ensuite effectivement moi j'avais besoin
de contrer de deux grands ennemis que
sont le temps qu'ils passent et la
solitude
donc ça c'est essentiel donc c'est vrai
qu'on est on est face à son ordinateur
finalement on envoie des cv seule elle
envoie des cv on à douala un os voilà le
temps de l'employeur n'est pas le ton du
demandeur d'emploi qui suit attend des
réponses rapides les meilleurs hits and
sons ne sont pas les miennes un
téléphone qui sonne pas en fait plutôt
plutôt en mode silencieux
donc là on arrive au sein de
l'association voilà on a réglé
rapidement alors ses accompagnateurs ils
vous font simplement parler mais je
pense pas que parler au nom bien sûr je
voudrais quand même revenir sur sûr
isolement et la solitude moi je vais
vraiment en tête le mental pour moi si
je voulais
avancez réussir c'est le mental le
mental le mental avoir la forme garder
la pêche voilà garder le moral et donc
je suis allé vers jean claude yves
kisombe de mes deux accompagnateurs dans
dont yves qui est un ancien
d'accompagner donc il a connu ce que je
connais il a une expérience
significative dans le domaine donc ça
ajoute de la crédibilité à la démarche
ensuite bon ce qui est important aussi
préciser c'est que ce sont des bénévoles
donc ils prennent de leur temps
il n'y a pas de prestations rémunérées
donc c'est gratuit c'est absurde et
compris un certain nombre de d'ateliers
va être proposée d'ailleurs
et là ce sont des prestations toujours
gratuit donc moi ce qui m'intéressait
c'est la relation humaine ça c'est pas
super à même d'en expliquer dans
quelques instants
est ce que ça vous a apporté
concrètement et vous en êtes dans votre
situation à faire une première pause on
est allé dans les rues de saint quentin
pour demander aux gens comment soutenir
quelle solution tout cas pour soutenir
moralement les demandeurs d'emploi et on
écoute les réponses tirait essayer de
les faire participer à la vie sociale
pour pas qu'ils soient isolés et leur
donner goût
on dit toujours au travail mais en fin
de compte a déjà participé à faire des
choses les soutenir être avec away tout
à fait de façon à pouvoir rechercher
plus facilement mais c'est super dur
trouver du boulot
ils vous disent peut-être leur dire
aujourd'hui nous qui avons eu la chance
de travailler comme on voulait on vous
souhaite
on en comprend plus exactement votre
votre problème et bon comment les aider
leur donnait des conseils de notre
propre expérience
en discutant avec eux à leur encontre en
peut-être en trouvant des endroits où on
pourrait essayer de monter quelque chose
après chômeurs et personnes retraitées
ou d'un chien ou bien j'ai personnes qui
travaillent alors je reviens avec vos
dominait depuis quand même temps vous
êtes au cnc ont travaillé ensemble
depuis cinq mois salut voila donc on
s'est déjà vu un petit bilan vous ai
droit de tout dire à votre
accompagnateur qui est à côté
vous pouvez en gros qu'est-ce que alors
qu'est ce que ça vous à preuve les
dirigeants ils vont se voit on se voit
régulièrement
concrètement il y a bon il ya des
discussions assez libre dans la
simplicité c'est créatif on discute de
nouvelles pistes auxquelles je n'aurais
pas forcément penser par exemple pour
une réorientation de carrière pour ça
peut aller jusque là alors pas une
remise en cause ou une remise en cause
mais je dirais que la remise en cause
elle elle se doit presque d'être
permanente
c'est un état d'esprit une attitude donc
oui il ya de la remise en cause donc moi
je souhaite changer de secteur
d'activité
donc effectivement il ya quand même un
vrai beau travail comment vous étiez
dans lequel ça leur a donné la vie tu
nous comme ça s'il ya des gens qui
travaillent dans la fonction commerciale
donc je souhaite toujours travailler
dans la fonction commerciale
mais aujourd'hui je souhaite
orienté vers le fun ii résigne donc la
levée de fonds auprès d'une grosse à
soho où l'une ou d'une fondation ou de
l'économie solidaire
pourquoi pas est ce donc il en coûte par
exemple est ce que dans ce cas de
dominique vous pouvez apporter des
pistes vous avez des carmina dresse est
ce que ça sert aussi à ça votre assiette
l'association effectivement si vous
voulez on peut apporter un certain
nombre des deux techniques j'ai parlé
tout à l'heure
des ateliers y circulent également dans
l'association
un certain nombre de d'annonce sur des
postes que nous communiquons à nous
accompagner enfin quand c'est quand ces
annonces les intéresse est également et
il ya un certain nombre de commandes
iraj de systèmes autour des réseaux et
en particulier dominique a pu
effectivement bénéficié comme ça d'une
mise en relation par notre intermédiaire
dans un réseau qui va lui ouvrir un
certain nombre de pistes je ne sais pas
j'espère qu'elle trouvera un emploi par
cet intermédiaire mais effectivement
c'est arrivé par notre part nous voilà
alors voilà un certain nombre d'outils
précis que nous offrons on se contente
pas simplement d'écouter effectivement
je vous l'avais dit ce sont des
bénévoles qui officie au sein de
solidarités nouvelles face au chômage
sont des gens qui sont en activité des
jeunes retraités alors est ce que vous
recherchez des bénévoles
alors les accompagne est les
accompagnateurs sont
globalement d'ailleurs dans
l'association et sur 50 ans était
exactement pareil soit des gens qui ont
effectivement une activité
professionnelle soit des dix ont des
jeunes retraités c'est à dire des
retraités qui ont derrière eux un passé
professionnel etion qui ont des
compétences qui veulent un petit peu les
les valoriser et qui ont ce qui est très
important qui ont du temps par rapport
aux gens qu'ils sont
parallèlement poste vidéo il n'ya pas
une différence est plus difficile et en
restreignant les temps d'autant plus
qu'il n'ya pas de limite de temps dans
l'accompagnement qui n'ont rien c'est à
dire qu'il n'ya pas de limite de
taureaux la personne peut rester jusqu'à
ce qu'elles retrouvent un emploi qu'elle
n'ait plus envie de les les statistiques
globales de l'association c'est que au
bout d'un accompagnement moyen d'environ
8 9 mois 60% des gens soit vous
retrouver un emploi soit aux sons sur
une piste qui va leur permettre de
retrouver un emploi
voilà voilà si vous parlez des
statistiques vous savez combien de
personnes vous avez réussi à ramener
comme ça vers l'emploi si vous voulez le
nous suivons bonhomme un nom
environ 20 à 30 ou 40 20 40 personnes
maximum donc sur saint-quentin voilà à
peu près notre action mais il c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui pour rebondir sur ce que
vous disiez tout à l'heure c'est que
j'ai une liste d'attentes assez
importante de demandeurs d'emploi et que
je manque donc ça c'est l'effet crise
d'accompagnateur si l'effet crise c'est
la crise mais vraisemblablement qui bien
entendu qu'ils jouent hélas mais
effectivement il serait important de
pouvoir recruter de nouveaux accompagne
hot mais je crois qu'il ya un monde où
un cas du s'affiche avec vos coordonnées
si des gens veulent me veulent vous
contacter merci en tout cas à vous
d'être venu dans la chronique échos du 7
8 et puis je rappelle on l'a pas dit
pouvoir initier une fois par mois au
centre alfred de vigny à un voisin un
voisin le bretonneux et vos services
sont gratuits
tout à fait merci à mes jouets offerts
mme catherine de numéros de téléphone
cette affiche est allé l'avant le guen
corps voilà
et puis quand ça vous dans vos
recherches les infos en plus de la
chronique est qu à présent alors l'info
en plus de ce soir elles concernent le
secteur du bâtiment est le coup de bol
on peut lire comme sa poussée par daniel
taravel assez le président de la
fédération chinoise du bâtiment alors
pour lui trop c'est trop il le dit la
profession souffre depuis 2011 estime le
président il pointe du doigt la hausse
de la tva réduite qui devrait passer au
1er janvier 2014 de 7 à 10%
il met aussi en avant l' accroissement
de la taxation sur les plus values
immobilières
et pour lui 2012 a été mauvaise et bien
2013 sera morose voilà et puis daniel
taravella il se rappela viendra sarkozy
s'est dit mardi où c'est donc un coup de
gueule il avait déjà exprimé il ya
quelques temps il reviendra parce que
effectivement les choses ne se sont pas
améliorées pour des informations alors
celle-ci elle concerne le siège social
de mercedes qui va s'implanter à
montigny on a beaucoup parlé
blanc peut vous donner juste une info
c'est concernant la pose de la première
pierre
je viens vraiment réel non pas parce
virtuel pour l'instant voilà la première
place soit donc posé le mercredi 13
février
la c4 dans cette chronique et de l'écho
ce sera à suivre bien évidemment dans
les prochaines éditions du 7 8 dans un
instant nous allons nous intéresser à
une
une initiative qui ne manque pas de
charme puisque à un jardin d'enfants
s'installent dans une maison de retraite
vous le verrez c'est tout à fait
intéressant mais puisque vous parliez du
secteur du bâtiment voilà une nouvelle
qui pourrait les rassurer l'urbanisation
prochaine du quartier des bécanes c'est
à la verrière à la concertation auprès
de la population vient de débuter un
reportage réalisé samedi dernier par
valérie auribeau et patrick jacques de
dixmude
la première concertation du projet
européen gare bécane de la verrière a
démarré en fanfare samedi dernier autour
des tables verrier roi et lui est maître
d'ouvragé
le projet comprend l'aménagement du lac
delage de la marine
la mère se baptisent automatiquement
quelques mois on aura des suds donner la
parole aux verriers roi c'était le but
de cette première concertation les élus
recueillait les attentes
les réflexions mais aussi les critiques
de la population on parle d'autres
expériences et justement fait en fait on
définit ce qui est positif dans la ville
ce qui l'est moins ce qui est négatif et
on s'appuie sur eux sur cette réfection
justement pour à terme en fait proposé
proposer des solutions mais on est
vraiment là dans la phase diagnostic
la démarche est très intéressante parce
que ça là on s'engage pour les dix ans
je verrai peut-être pas le cette ville
mais c'est intéressant de partir de
d'une friche des friches agricoles pour
arriver à une ville nouvelle
dans ce projet priorité aux logements
sociaux mais aussi au développement des
transports afin de désenclaver la ville
de plus l'installation d'une zone
d'activité permettrait de multiplier les
offres d'emploi dans une commune
particulièrement marquée par le chômage
pour autant la question d'augmenter les
impôts le projet serait financé par des
partenaires publics et privés et les
nouveaux arrivants
d'autres ateliers de concertation plus
approfondie devra se dérouler dès le
mois de février